hey guys it's alone and i'm currently
here at the o in 15 years more time
hadn't asked fans burst where it's
actually one of the first times in the
world that beeper is actually playable
so let's go check it out
i know i am here with Chris who is the
Asia Pacific community manager on EA
Sports what you do tell me that is so
fantastic about FIFA 15 this team to you
about 15 yeah I'll probably start
talking about the visuals as you saw
yourself have got the real-time effects
on the grass so you know if a player
puts a big divot in the grass at one
stage of the match it's going to be in a
hole man I didn't think that was really
cool that's pretty cool also we have you
can see the pie sufficiently breathing
down you know the way the jersey sales
of applauding it's very realistic so it
looks great for it for the next gen
consoles adjust the main that's more
familiar what's your favorite thing
about FIFA 15 favorite thing geez it's a
hard question okay my favorite thing is
that in terms of of the slightest fifa
players players will know if you're
behind you might go to ultra tacky we've
actually gone further now you can
actually go to your all-out attack yeah
and as I'm defending instead of
something else with a fancy dinner and
talk with us yeah so as you to really
dramatically change the way you
football is the greatest draw on earth
this is our stage our theater
I was born into it
others were adopted
but we're all connected if you don't
believe we're family you haven't felt
what we felt agony tension heartbreak
but that moment when it comes together
just right
words cannot describe
so we're seeing right now is an added s
competition where basically people put
on the new added us predator birds so
there's like a fitting area and
everything and then they hit as many
targets as I can in one minute with a
soccer ball and the person with the
highest score at the end of the night
wins a $350 autodesk voucher i'm not
going to enter myself because that would
just be embarrassing but it honestly is
a really cool thing to just have over
the side of this enormous video game
setup it's really cool like a clash of
two worlds
thank you so much this has been crisp
Alden and I will see you guys next time
thank you 1 feel the game